[Music]
well thanks for coming out my name is
Skye Bates I run data for lyft data at
lyft is basically data platforms data
engineering and a whole bunch of data
applications that we built before that I
was at Facebook for about six years and
then before that I've done all sorts of
crazy stuff in my career everything from
like big brokerages to television
networks to giant fusion lasers out in
the desert but pretty much the whole
time it's been data so I'm glad to be
here and I'm happy to answer any
questions and share like what little
wisdom I managed to accumulate through
making many mistakes in my life all
right I'm Jasmine I'm director of data
platform at Clover health we are
actually an insurance Medicare Advantage
company but using data to improve
healthcare our data team at their
engineering team we have some
representative this year there's about
15 people right now and then the data
science team is about the same size so
it's a measure that's fun I don't have
the same very background before software
engineering I was actually in science
which is only barely relevant I'm Noelle
Saldana I would run a data science team
for a pivotal if everyone heard of
pivotal all right and especially if
you're in the last talk you hopefully
over to the middle which both has is a
past company as well as has a consulting
arm so that we have both data scientists
and data engineers on our team I have
been a pivotal for seven years or so now
and I've been doing data science before
a data science I think was called data
science and so how could we here dude
yeah so I guess today we're gonna be
talking about hiring in data probably
from both sides from Pete's question to
the audience that looks like a lot of
you are hiring rather the
being hired but I think you've all
probably had the experience of being on
the other side of the table and have had
some frustrations just curious a quick
show of hands how many of you have had
to do a lengthy take home assignment as
part of a data science or data
engineering alright so what we'll be
touching on that and how many of you
have seen job descriptions where you're
looking you're like this company does
not know what a data scientist is
fantastic well we'll touch on things
like that as well so that's a good
transition to my first question to the
panel and just you know what is data
engineering and data science but this
point is this a well known mainstream
field are there still things that are
being figured out how would you guys
define the work that you do there's a
great blog by Monica riccati about the
hierarchy of AI needs I don't know if
everyone's seen it but has AI at the top
and goes down through everything from
like data cleaning down to like data
gathering and I think there's like a
natural like fuzzy line in the middle of
it where I think data engineering would
be at the bottom and data science would
be at the top but everybody I think in
the field has skill sets across all of
those and depending on where your
emphasis is and depending on what
company you work for it defines it
slightly differently yeah I would
absolutely agree I very much think of a
skills as a spectrum and when we
actually started thinking about it like
that for hiring it makes a much more
effective hiring process for you because
you're not looking for like silo corners
of that spectrum and it's much more easy
to evaluate holistically I definitely
don't think is a mastering idea yet it's
a mainstream buzzword sure but like I
believe that it's very much dependent on
the company and the more important thing
is for your company to define it crisply
for its own goals and needs it doesn't
really matter how the rest of the
industry defines it as long as you can
communicate what the vision of that is
for your for your team's yeah I would
say for data science in the industry
like the term is hopelessly screwed up
it is
like you really don't know [ __ ] about a
job the science it could be anything
from like requires three PhDs to do
autonomous driving to like as long as
you know a little bit of sickle and you
can monkey some Excel you're in business
right so it's really important to redo
the job descriptions and find out like
okay like what is this person really
looking for you know what do they really
want what is success for this job what
are the skills that are coming in I
think data engineering is better formed
like data engineering almost always
means like taking raw data and
transforming it into something that's
usable and efficient and accurate and
and easy for customers to consume but
the methodologies of doing that can vary
quite a bit too there's sort of like the
old-school data engineering world which
is mostly like tool driven like ETL
informatica things like that and then
there's sort of the newer Silicon Valley
approach which is much more of a
programmers job and you know much more
lower level and usually dealing with
like much larger volumes of data
yeah I'm not know I think there's also
like a difference between the tools
writers versus the pipeline writers and
how much of the front end of data you
touch yeah one one thing I was curious
about I don't know if in the past
probably a pasture up certainly not at
your current employers but has somebody
come to you and said you you understand
the data you know tell us this how can
you fix all our problems I hope you have
somebody ask a very ridiculous question
to you that somebody that's not familiar
with the field would would think data
science consult and I'd say especially
when the date the article that came out
about data science is the sexiest you
know thing we got a lot of that and I
think to this day you gather there are
people who don't know what it is and so
they'll come we get people like I've
been told my CEO or by the whomever that
we need to do deep learning great what
kind of data do you have like it's all
structured or like it fits in Excel like
like I don't you keep using that word
deep learning and so if every few years
there's a new like handful of terms that
we see I see like people who have been
told by someone else they need AI or
like the next best thing and like and in
order to do that II need a higher a data
scientist and like that will magically
help fix their problems and it's well
yeah you mentioned that in some cases
people are requiring three PhDs for
anonymous try anonymous autonomous I'm
something that's top of mind for me
autonomous driving in a lot of ways you
know data science and data and hiring
are still a little more Wild West than
other fields of probably even more than
software engineering which is a bit
older certainly more than law and
medicine
so part of this is you know what your
own backgrounds are but also when you
are hiring for your teams and you are
looking at a candidate how can you tell
before you talk to them if they're good
and probably answers you can't really
but what what proxies are actually
valuable in this field given that it's
new so generally you can't tell much
from a resume other than where somebody
worked right and so you can sometimes
inherit like certain skills if someone
works at a company that's really
well-known for being good at a certain
thing like if someone's doing like data
engineering at Google they probably know
some stuff right but I usually don't pay
any attention to the bullets at all
honestly the thing that actually stands
out a lot and helps significantly is
open source contributions like if
someone can provide me with a link to
like code that they've actually
contributed to a project and you can
actually look through the code that they
wrote like that's way more valuable to
me than like any resume ever you know
and another thing that helps a lot is
like blog posts or things like that that
are similarly revealing where someone
can show you like a project they've done
or give you an example of some of the
things that they've they've actually
like written you know like because at
the end of the day what really matters
is what you can do not like what how you
form the word soon so those are the
things that often help a lot
we also generally assume that no matter
what anybody says that we still need to
test for everything
there's very rarely like any kind of
like a pass you know for the the core
interview I think this question also
applies for general software engineering
right you it's very similar there's no
like credentialing process and software
engineering and what are you looking for
you know software engineering skill set
and so for me I think the most important
thing is like some sort of depth being
demonstrated if somebody's like jumped
around a lot or only written glue code
or you know it's kind of dabbler I think
that it's not necessarily as valuable
and I think depths can be demonstrated
not just through professional
contributions or open source but like
blog post or whatever and then
specifically for data some sort of
affinity for data it's very important
like that curiosity about why do you
care about data and like demonstrating
that you're willing to dig into issues I
think that is a quality that is you know
substantially different for this field
and some of the other one small note or
tip I would give about resumes to
demonstrate that depth would be to
quantify what you've done like in terms
of data like people they're like oh I've
had experience with data like that's
great how much data was it was that a
gigabyte was that a terabyte was that an
excel sheet was an Excel spreadsheet
doesn't know how like and if you're
trying to say like I've worked with big
data like what does that actually mean
like stay away from the buzzwords and if
you you're getting applying for a place
that wants you for your quantitative
skills like you should be able to tell
them like what the volume of the data
was at least on your resume
I just remembered this joke somebody
compared a big data to teenagers and sex
right everyone's talking about it
everyone thinks they have it but no
one's actually doing it right yeah one I
mean my opinion on resumes is that they
should die in a fiery pit so I certainly
agree with with you guys if if you were
to mention some red flags right so I
think it's very hard to tell if
someone's good from a piece of paper but
I think sometimes you can tell if
someone is unequivocally bad
with with some margin of error of course
sorry there are certain red flags that
pop out yeah there definitely are a few
like you know just lack of care and the
resume itself like spelling errors and
things like that that just seem
egregious the other thing I've noticed
is like if you can't even figure out
like what they are claiming you know
like if the resume basically doesn't
make sense that's a you know like I'll
read this blur but I'm like what is that
even you know like I don't even
understand what you're trying to tell me
you know and much less like what did you
do anything any kind of like bizarre
formatting like some sometimes you get
resumes with like mug shots and stuff
but it's like that is just poor judgment
yeah just stay away from that [ __ ] right
yeah but other than that you know like
usually it's just tell you tell me where
you've been and what you know give me a
job title and a general feeling for what
you thought your role was and then we'll
test for the rest of it a lot of the
other stuff is standard resume stuff and
definitely hey buzzwords this is just
not there is a game of optimizing for
that because recruiters to search for
that but yeah but it's really difficult
to read as a hiring manager and then
when technologies are combined together
in a way that don't make sense that's
very very telling it's probably in a lot
of ways if you're a hiring manager it's
easier to tell what depth looks like
then if you're a member of the
recruiting team who may not have domain
expertise right so how do you guys work
with recruiting to keep them from
falling back on credentialing that
especially in a new field may not carry
as much weight as they might like to
think so I don't have a lot to worry
about for that I think for her she is
really good at actually tying back the
data points like having a conversation
with a candidate
and then revisiting the resume and then
doing that feedback loop so for for me I
don't have a lot to worry about
absolutely process with the recruiters
like you can start with things like okay
look for this type of academic
background and give them a range like I
think part of it is giving them
parameters like okay it's not just look
for people with PhDs and statistics like
theirs there's a wide range especially
in our field but in also to tell them
like okay what has worked well what did
what's emerging as a pattern doing some
data science like on top of what you're
doing but also say that recruiters like
any other relationship like you get out
of it what you put into it so you have
to take the time to like train and help
them understand what you're looking for
and respond when you know they're either
giving you good candidates or bad ones
and it's just it's something you have to
invest in and then if you invest in it
like you get it you get it outcomes it's
good and it's really important to talk
about the profile sense of skillsets and
what does outcome for success look like
and then you have like here are possible
proxies of signals for that kind of
skill sets but you know make a really
clean mental model for that do you guys
ever find yourselves applying data
analysis techniques to recruiting in a
cross-functional way you touched on this
a little bit as an example alright you
know potentially going a little deeper
in and looking at the kinds of signals
you might be able to pull in and getting
predictive value from from resumes or
other parts of the process actually
tried really hard to get that to work
and the conclusion we came to is it just
kind of doesn't work I mean we do a lot
of analysis around like to see
operations of recruiting like
understanding the pipeline in the funnel
and you know where people are falling
off and what's a healthy funnel versus a
bad funnel and that kind of stuff just
to make sure that the the thing is
rolling but when it comes to like
crunching through somebody's resume
trying to derive whether they're going
to be a good or bad employee
yes yeah I think even if you just look
at some of your own top performers in
the team and then go refer back to their
resume or Lincoln profile there's just
all sorts of variation there and that's
already together pretty telling signal
so if someone is new to the field and
you know maybe they got out of a boot
camp which you know I'm mixed on I think
you guys are probably mixed on as well
but they're they're trying to get into
this field and let's assume they have
some amount of skill and baseline
competence how might they get noticed or
what can they do to get their foot in
the door if they look like [ __ ] on paper
right like get involved and get your
hands on it there's you know padding
your resume with here are all these
classes I've taken is not going to be as
compelling of peers as me trying to
apply it this is something that I wanted
to go learn and quite frankly doing
something like haggle is great but doing
something other than catechol like if
you want to stand out do something other
than cattle on your resume I you just
find like if they think it's everybody's
go-to alright and so it's everybody's
go-to and that also a lot of that data I
think tends to be cleaner because
they're trying to show like apples to
apples comparison and preparing the data
right and so like you know if what you
want to show a wider breadth of your
skill set especially as it relates to
engineering I think would be more
interesting like so I shameless plug
I've worked a lot with data kind and so
like working with like nonprofit
organizations and they for sure do not
have data people who work with them full
time and like that's it's not going to
be quite to the same scale that you'd
necessarily get in the industry but
certainly has very clear examples of
these are problems that could be solved
by date on here's a dirty data you can
you know try to do something with
there's a lot of very interesting
government data
they're like you know open data gov and
stuff like that like one of the places
where I wish I had more time just to
play around with I guess the other thing
I'd say is the idea that you hand a
resume to a job website is like the way
to get a job is just like completely
wrong right that is like the worst way
to ever try to get a job and it's almost
certain to failing the things that work
or network you know projects open source
contributions are good but you want to
bring a person into it somehow unless
you're like an absolute freaking
rockstar and your name is like
world-renowned you know like you you
need some kind of like way to bridge
that gap and not just let the the blind
submissions like I remember at Facebook
we got something like two hundred
thousand blind submissions like every
year you know so trying to troll through
all that and find you know the people
that are good versus the bad the other
thing is recruiters learned that
referrals and recruiters sourced is like
a much higher content and they're
typically you think about your average
recruiter he's incented on the number of
hires he manages to make so he's very
careful about how he uses his time right
he doesn't want to troll through the
200,000 in order to find one hire he
wants to use the high-quality sources
which are usually referrals and people
these sources himself program and then I
participate in the recruiting process
but that was many years ago as I got
very lucky my career and I think the
climate is very different now and I
would say you know all these points are
valid but a lot of it is about more
about timing and finding the right
company that is actually hiring
entry-level engineers or or have some
sort of vision for how they develop more
entry-level people because if you you
know trying to knock on a door that if a
company now has already decided that
they don't have capacity to take on
entry-level engineers is it's just not a
good use of your time so the networking
part and understanding what companies
are out there that is willing to take
that chance right now and what kind of
plan do they have for growing engineers
I think that part is actually the most
important for a really saturated market
right
and your guys's view what is the balance
of bringing on junior team members right
because in some what you want to be that
company that brings a new talent and
builds them up and then takes this very
long-term view of hiring and in some
cases you just don't have the bandwidth
and you have to get [ __ ] done right so
how do you think about that and where do
you draw the line I think it's really
important and valuable to have
entry-level people no matter you know
what stage you're had I mean unless
you're you know kind of like running out
of cash or something because I do like
actually for a while our de engineering
team was much more leaning towards very
senior or middle and senior people and
we I had this blind spot of like you
know we have to like build this
foundational part of our platform so we
don't really have like that capacity to
bring all more entry-level people and
then when we did I realized like I was
just totally wrong you know like the
dynamic of the team changed a lot
because what was happening was you know
all the senior level people kind of knew
what was going on so they didn't
document anything that well and then
like they were relying on what they
already know to to like navigate the
stack and I think there is a like a
tremendous amount of value to be forced
to not just like teach but also to think
about like the accessibility of the
software that you're building the tools
that you're building and and that is
like really really valuable to the team
but like obviously also like investing
in the future generation of engineer is
really important because everybody wants
to hire software engineers and no one
wants to train them I think that's just
that's that's focus you know that's
that's that's doing a little bit of free
living yeah I think I totally agree like
it you're looking for a balance right
the balance you're looking for it can be
different depending on what you're doing
the other thing I would say is when I
build up a team I usually want to have
at least one or two senior engineers on
the team like kind of cornerstone
engineers that can set direction
seen stuff happen before right and know
not to make like the common newbie
mistakes but then you also need like a
balance of like more junior people
because a lot of times that's actually
where the innovation happens you know
anybody can innovate but the junior
person that's like fresh out doesn't
actually know you know what's the
established way of doing things and
sometimes they'll go in like very
strange directions that actually turns
out to be really valuable right because
that's how we did it years ago but maybe
it doesn't make sense anymore right like
I need to scale this thing a team out
and let the team use a double in size
and then double again it's not going to
it's gonna be very expensive if you
wanted only hire senior people right and
then the best and that to your point
like to get the right people like you do
have to do your due diligence and it's
so specialized in a lot of ways for
every company like trying to hire senior
people for what you need in your company
it's better to find them and train them
when they're wrong raw talented people
are great for expanding a team for
thinking you know [ __ ] it might be time
to hire a junior person even though we
don't really want to like what are the
the signs that you can do it and you
have the bandwidth I mean I think that I
just think about it as a distribution
you know like do I want like 20 to 30%
of my team to be like you know level 3
or low 4 and then like another 30% to be
like mid-range and then maybe like
another 30% to be senior or do I want to
skew it in one direction or the other
so speaking of hiring and kind of coming
back to some of the stuff we talked
about at the very beginning let's talk a
little bit about interview process he's
so you know whether someone's junior or
senior you get them in I know all of
your companies do things just a little
bit differently so how do you guys hire
today I think everybody goes through a
similar process so there's usually an
initial screen the resume
to hitting on the different sources but
everybody does get screened by HR a
front like we talked about working with
our recruiters and then it goes through
a technical screen there might be some
sort of technical exercise depending on
which role you're applying for in
particular whether or not yeah if
there's technical exercise and then for
us and then an on-site and since we're
consultants part of the part of what we
have to screen for especially in person
is how would you be in front of a
customer like how would you be
presenting how comfortable are you
thinking on your feet and then that's
part of the process and you know lots of
FaceTime with people I think everybody
has some version of that process for us
I think the most important thing to me
is that the interview process be
repeatable and consistent like one of
the things it's very common a mistake to
make is to have sort of a random
interview process where one particular
set of people is very hard and one
particular set is very easy and what you
end up with in it's like a random set of
hires right so it's it's not just the
different loops you know the different
interviews that happen but also the
people that give them and the questions
that get asked you have to be very well
calibrated you know so the idea is that
you're asking the same from the same
book of questions that people are asking
that that set of questions in a way that
they understand it really well and
they've asked it many times and they
know what a good answer is which is a
great answer versus a mediocre answer I
think the another thing that we work a
lot on at lyft is trying to make sure
that we eliminate unconscious bias like
there's a lot of unconscious bias that
happens in hiring you know this
discrimination that just goes on in
people's brains it's hard to like
short-circuit but one of the things that
we found that's pretty good is like
blind grading of code so you know you
the idea is you come in you do it like a
laptop interview you write some code the
person that's like there with you grades
it but we also have like a blind grader
that had knows nothing about the
candidate hasn't seen the resume doesn't
know ethnicity or any of that stuff
right and all they have is the code they
grade it as well and then we know
firstly like we remove a bias and the
decision but we're also calibrating that
actual interviewer like if his judgment
on that code starts to differ from the
blind graders and there's there's
thing that used to get resolved like why
are they different I wish we could
figure out a way to do that on all the
interviews but so far we have no just
two random interviewer but they they
don't know anything though right they
have no context no no resume no nothing
you guys actually use our product yeah
yeah you guys actually interview people
never having seen their resume
completely blind as well and I love
working point about making sure that
you're pulling from like in a common
pool of questions across your
interviewers and I remember a few years
ago when we were expanding our data
science team someone know it because we
collect all of our feedback and we're
looking through it like are we too harsh
like is everyone to like win at what
point did we get so mean right did we
get so and we like pick the questions
like oh this person couldn't state this
theorem and this candidate couldn't and
once we actually like added like and
every single person had went on there of
the question they answer like could any
single one of us have passed this
interview we have to recalibrate and
bring it down like asking more
open-ended questions and not make it a
textbook exam because that's not the
point
stuff that I want to call out is one is
on side panel we actually have always
have two interviewers instead of one I
think that helps to calibrate some of
the by stuff a lot also helps to train
interviewers much faster and get to
convergence and consistency the other
thing is we try to make sure our
exercises actually reflect what we do so
instead of like theoretical stuff it's
very much based on the actual kind of
coding that you will do the kind of
domain exercise we try to do our system
design exercise in a way that like also
teach you something about healthcare can
be fun
that's a great segue into talking about
oh oh I guess one other thing the
questions need to provide signal like a
good question will tolerate a gradient
of answers right like it's not a binary
like either you got it or you didn't a
good question will have people that
flunk it people that pass it people that
do like mediocre on it and you'll
understand like where those watermarks
are that's that's a very important thing
like one of the things we've done wrong
before is have questions with a lot that
rely on like a single insight right like
you you see this insight and you get the
question right or you don't see that
insight and you totally miss the
question that's actually not a good
question because like you never know
whether you're gonna have that insight
or not right
or maybe they rely on the people of
certain like piece of trivia right like
you know about this particular data
structure then you're in business and if
you don't know you're screwed right so
so a gradient is important it also lets
you use the question for different
levels of seniority so like I can I can
give this question to like a mid-level
person I expect them to get this far a
like advanced person will get all the
way through right you know so it lets
you kind of like level people as well
the same person interviewing with a ton
of different interviewers and will look
at how they do either over time or over
a short span of time and questions that
layer complexity and don't have some
kind of AHA thing tend to get the most
deterministic results and otherwise
people are all over the place salsa
means as a candidate don't get work been
out of shape if you didn't get all the
question right like maybe you weren't
even expected to write like maybe you
did you did better than you thought you
would just and a lot of times it's more
about like how you attack it and like
how far you get through it and then it
is like oh you totally solved it
perfectly right that you can just keep
going forever so they think they did
really poorly because they feel like
they didn't finish it right when in
reality they got through five of the
seven levels and most people only
getting like if you're really suck the
interviewer will end it after two and
tell you you did a great job yeah so I
think one of the closing questions I
won't ask this is something I'm I have a
lot of strong opinions about and want to
see what you guys think is just
take-home assignments or
what makes it what makes one good what
makes one bad when should you use them
when shouldn't you I know that in data
engineering and data science they're a
little more prevalent than in software
engineering because you're working with
data and that's a good way to see how
people work with data we need to do more
take-home assignments especially for
candidates who were coming straight out
of school and we noticed that practice
but I think what we ended up finding is
that it just gave a wide range even
though we said this should only take you
an hour we expect an hour and then we
would get twenty pages worth of like
beautifully type things like mmm I don't
think this is actually reflective and I
we didn't get insight into how people
think through their process and so it
was we move more towards like pairing
like pairing interviews for other I know
it's a pivotal way right and so yeah I
think in some cases it might have made
sense but the variance was really really
wide yeah I pretty much hate him it
comes back to the idea that questions
need to provide signal like if someone
does well on a take home assignment the
signal I have is somewhere in the world
there's somebody that knows how to do
that assignment like I have no idea that
it's a person that's sitting in front of
me and you know I've seen some seriously
weird [ __ ] in interviews in my time I
remember we had an instance where the
person that did the phone screen was not
the person they came to the on site so
there are no high jinks that don't
happen and like there are some like
areas where people are very organized
about this stuff right so I just I can't
trust a signal so I don't know know what
good it is for me so I'd rather just
have them do it where I could like see
them do it right it's not a gate and we
very explicitly made that decision
because I think that is what leads to
all the failure modes that you're
mentioning I do feel conflicted about
some of the implications like how much
time do you know this is like personal
spending on it obviously penalizes
certain certain categories of people
so definitely so feel conflicted about
that but I think we still have gotten a
lot of signal out of them
because they're not a gate to the on
site and basically it becomes an
exercise where we're kind of doing a
pair programming exercise when we're
doing on site instead of doing some
other weird coding exercise yeah more it
uses it pretty well like they have a
take home assignment which is like
present like a product you built so it's
kind of like different for every
candidate but then the thing they do
that's smart is they they drill the
person right like they're like okay like
it's the person is spending like 45
minutes presenting this they ask all
sorts of questions and like yeah really
dig in and so there's no way you could
fake it essentially like and I'm
guessing you all have some burning
questions for this group of fine people
so so we know we know not to send your
proxy it's your in-person interview
while you're thinking a question like
you I just wanted to ask one for the
panel so in my experience I've
discovered that engineers recruit other
engineers best how do you inspire aside
from the interview process which is
always distributed through the
engineering team at least as far as I've
seen how do you inspire your engineering
team to get involved in the hiring
process well there's a couple ways right
like one of them is if you're hiring for
your team it's usually kind of easy to
do because you realize this is a person
that you want to work with that you know
it's good and that like we'll do some of
the work that otherwise you have to do
so for for cross team hiring we often do
two things one is we do do referral
bonuses right like that's a real thing
we'll also pull out like certain parts
of the company what we think are
struggling and we'll sort of do a call
to action and we'll say like oh my god
we really need Android engineers let's
do like a ninja hunt we'll get like a
bunch of people together we'll feed on
pizza like we'll all go through our
LinkedIn will find Android engineers
will produce like referrals right and
then it turns into kind of like a party
so it's fun
I would say you shouldn't take away your
engineers agency I think in a lot of
large companies if you want to refer
somebody in you have to go to this
recruiting machine and kind of submit
their name and then hope something
happens so you're using your political
and social capital at the same time
right on one hand you're like putting in
this effort and then if the person
doesn't do well you feel stupid and on
the other hand if it's a friend of yours
you know like what if the recruiting
team doesn't get back to them you're
gonna look dumb in front of your friend
right and and social pressure is much
more painful than really anything else
so you want to just reduce that friction
and reward it like even if they refer
ten shitty people in a row you're like
you know what this is a good engineer
just keep taking their candidates and
thank them for it and make it easy don't
make them jump through hoops and if they
want to hire for their team don't make
that person get dumped into some central
process where they're never heard from
again
much easier said than done certainly
smaller companies it's easier question
here thanks so much for the panel the
question I have has to do with
specialization and generalization what
would you say it's candidates who maybe
feel they don't fit into the mold of the
position that they're seeing at the
company they want to work at for example
somebody who is a strong data scientist
did work a series a stage company for a
couple years and did a lot of product
type thinking to and found they really
liked that and they have an identity now
as an interdisciplinary in almost to the
point where they're not just t-shaped
but maybe they're kind of like pie
shaped perhaps and and they like that
and they're good at it but how would how
should they talk to the larger companies
especially about that yeah this is a
real problem there are holes in a
company or I like square holes
rectangular holes like oblong holes
companies really like people that fit
those holes and you know they will often
tolerate it like a little bit of
deviation from the whole but where they
get into trouble is like like you were
saying like somebody that's just not
that you know like a real honest-to-god
like hybrid or strange combination of
disciplines there's two things that are
about those people if you find them the
right role they can be like amazing like
because they bring together in their
head like stuff that your company
doesn't have you know in sight one head
and that can allow connections and idea
is to sprout that is like you know it
can really change you the second thing
is organizationally you don't know what
to do with them right so the only answer
that I have to that is I think that good
managers notice and they will say like
okay so you're you're you're weird
you're weird fish you know like you
don't fit into these holes like I want
that you know so it's really kind of
like the only thing I've ever seen is
like manager intervention at the end of
the day like I've never seen a company
that actually has managed to get the
benefit of these standardized roles
which they do come with a lot of benefit
and yet still be able to accommodate
like the people that don't fit into them
well I think of my own career and I'm a
non-standard hire like I don't have a
PhD like I didn't I took one CS class as
a grad student you know and it was a
time where they didn't know what mmm the
options you had is an applied
mathematician when I got started was
like oh you can be an actuary or you
could go teach right and so great I got
really lucky that I somebody I had a
company founded role or the entry-level
entry-level that they were willing to
teach me how to code and had a manager
who's like I I see where your talent is
like have you ever touched our no idea
what that is right and that you know
I've been able to learn a lot and you
know just hustle
to get where I've gotten which has been
really great but it was you know kind of
luck kind of circumstance but also also
believing that like there's something
out there like don't get discouraged if
you're a non non standard hire don't get
discouraged that there's you know like
your round and every second every hole
is square
process a little bit and in like dukling
decisive the company matters a lot I
think though it's important that if you
come with a really generous background
where people can't totally fit like this
is where you fit it's important to come
with your own like narrative of this is
what you want it to because then a
conversation becomes much easier you
know because sometimes the failure modes
of like having this like punish a
person's you know you don't know where
they're gonna focus and that high
oppai shape okay and you don't know if
like maybe maybe it's also a reflection
of like they like to jump around a lot
and that things that don't keep their
interest for a very long time so I I
think it's important to make sure that
you articulate what it assigned you
would like to achieve and what value you
think you can bring hi um one thing that
came up was open source contributions
and blog posts I think for some of us
who are newer to the field were a little
more intimidated by that and like I've
never I I've never had an open source
contribution and it can be very
discouraging to hear when that's kind of
a filtering factor so I'm curious to
hear more about that and and the level
that plays into filtering someone out
it's not a filter like it's not like oh
you didn't do it you can't get hired
right it's just like a very nice bonus
you wouldn't be amazed actually like a
lot of these projects are quite
interested in new people and realize
that exactly what you said is a problem
like a easy way to get around that is to
just state it just like you mentioned
like shoot an email to the dev list and
say like I am new I want to like get
involved in this I'm willing to put work
in and then the second thing I would say
is like demonstrate that you're actually
willing to put work in because there's a
lot of folks to think that they want to
do this and then they realize it's
actual work and they back out and so
before the the maintainer czar gonna
want to like invest in you they want to
at least know that you're serious about
it you're actually gonna do something
sometimes like this fixing a couple of
little bugs which is not like super hard
you know but like they've been sitting
there for a while is enough till I kind
of earn that
yeah it is a thing that is you know hard
to overcome I think they won't it won't
stop you like it's not a requisite for
getting a job or anything I've written a
lot of stuff on the internet now but
it's really scary to get started
and I actually got started on Quora
because one you know what people want to
read about so you don't have to
artificially think of a topic and - it
feels so good when people press up phone
and then over time you start to get a
better feeling for your audience and
what they want to hear about and what
kind of tone works so it's a it's like
if you're a comedian you go to some
little club no one's heard of and just
try out material like that's what Cora
can be and it's it's if no one no one
uploads it then probably no one's ever
seen it so it's fun as someone who was
like two months into my data inch career
and came from software engineering but I
just graduate a little while ago I know
very well about studying for like
interviews especially software
engineering interviews and you mentioned
that you like your interview process to
be repeatable we love it when you're
repeatable because that means we can
find the questions but I want to know
from your guys's perspective how do you
kind of like beat that mentality like
you make sure that you don't have to
deal with people who just learned the
question online but how do we also
prepare ourselves to handle these types
of like new questions like data
engineering questions data science
questions yeah there's there's generally
like a some kind of like question
database where things get marked once
they are out in the wild so usually you
don't discover it right away but you'll
figure out like oh this questions
actually out there you know and then you
just mark it and you never use it again
and so there's a constant like shuffling
we also at Facebook we tend to expire
them just automatically after a period
of time we just kind of assume they get
out there I think another one is just to
have a big enough scent like you're not
talking about like five questions or ten
questions you're talking about like 20
or 30 or 40 or 50 and then the odds that
somebody has like studied all of those
sayings or not like super great right
it's so the other question was like how
to prepare for it like I usually you
know if you think about
the questions we ask they kind of fall
into two categories one is like this
general programming where you know if
you're a good programmer you'll be able
to answer it you don't really have to
study I would just sharpen up right on
like draw programming skills and then
the second ones are usually like design
and architecture and like how would you
actually put something together and
there's really like also no way to study
that but that's where like some of the
theory comes in like you know complexity
analysis and being able to talk about
time and space constraints sometimes you
want to crack open like you know the old
textbook and remind yourself like how
that [ __ ] works does that help at all
maybe they get the first one and then
you're like let's change it up let's
yeah you can also shake it around a
little bit if you start to you can
sometimes get a feeling that all this
kind of feels like wrote you know yes
let's let's throw some stuff in there
like I look well a lot of times rather
than picking an obscure data set and
asking people to work in it tell me
about what your last project was what
could you've gone if you could change
something about it now that you have it
in hindsight what would you have done
differently why did you choose the
things that you did and just
understanding people's creativity and
their thought process is one something
you can't study for and two like so much
more important like it really doesn't
matter if the question is out there
because people can answer in so many
different ways and the point of an
interview is to see if we can be smart
together and I just love that that's
stuck with me and I think that that's
the kind of interviewing you have to do
if you subscribe to that - two more
questions my question is so you
mentioned that like that the open source
contributions and the blockbuster kunuk
an indicator whereas for me like the
blockbusters anyone can write blog
because it's not a peer-reviewed process
you can see that I'm from academic
background I love peer-review whereas an
open source contribution is like strong
indicator so one thing I realized like
where we realized that like right now
the in the absence of liquid that engine
I recommend our like hiring team or like
that team to like to test if this person
is multiple intellect could that
engineer that a scientist what should be
the things we should look out for well I
mean to be a data engineer is just a
subset of a software engineer right like
the most important skills are core
software engineering skills especially
people that are familiar with back-end
systems can usually make that leap like
pretty easily and we actually don't
require you to had past experience you
know doing data engineering we expect
you to understand like back-end systems
and you know scalability and things like
that
so you know I think that it's like less
of a barrier I think it's probably
trickier as a data scientist but I'll
let these ladies answer because I don't
really know too much about that he's
trying he's trying to get at like you're
not always able to find people that
exactly fit the profile how do you find
people that can learn it it's
interesting so there's two different
categories of things I look for for data
scientists one is technical ability
right so like can they code you have a
capacity to code like I don't really
care what language like can date code
and then the same thing with math right
like do they have some mathematical
statistic instinct or background in it
that you know that they'll have some
starting point like I don't go through a
laundry list of you need to know all of
these ten algorithms or you're going to
fail right great how do you ensure that
there's diversity on your team several
of the things that you mentioned were
about using network using your personal
networks and if many of us here I think
are in tech and tech is a notorious for
having terrible diversity then how do
you get out of that system and same
thing with using open source
contributions people that have the means
and have much more availability in their
time to actually do that so how do you
get people who have less time available
because either they need to do parenting
or take care of elderly parents or
things like that thank you for asking
that question
thrilled for me like I care very deeply
about that and one of the things I told
my recruiters at one point was like I
don't want to move to on-site interviews
until I've at least screened you know X
number of women I have done 20
interviews of like guys like there's not
easy like where's the diversity in our
pipelines like well there are the people
who applied aren't diverse my GLAAD and
let's add some diversity to the pipeline
I can't manifest diversity on my team if
there's no diversity in my pipeline so
it's being really active about that
really like we can't move forward to the
next place if we don't have diversity
and if it takes more effort to make it
to ensure that in the pipeline maybe
they're less maybe we need to broaden it
a little bit I went through actually all
of our back to the resumes like are we
are we prematurely screening people out
because they're not non-standard
candidates because they don't have the
right buzzwords because they don't have
the right background and trying to
really understand make sure that like
every step of the pipeline for us has
diversity I think we're not just trying
to hire so fast that we're just gonna
get the first five people and like okay
we first five hires then you do that the
next thing you're like wow my whole team
kind of looks the same like six hires
and at what point do you stop like
there's no good point I don't think to
stop and say like oh we should think
about diversity now right like it's
always too late if you've gone to that
point right I think the top of funnel
diversity is really really important
because when you start to get lower in
the process it really trickles down
amplifies and then it also gets trickier
so really investing in that it's really
important I wouldn't say we have like
Neoga in any way there's still a lot
more to do the other thing I think
growing people and retaining them is
really important I think a lot of people
have hire a lot of these entry-level
like minority background engineers and
then they just lose them after a few
years because they haven't really
invested in growing them
on that level yeah it's a huge problem
right like I think that if you think
about diversity it starts actually
probably in middle school you know we
had this sociological like attempts to
for whatever reason push women out of
the more technical disciplines and the
end the result is that by the time you
get to college like you've already we've
already lost the battle right like if
you look at the graduating rate of like
you know engineers and what not and how
they have they are diverse or not
diverse like it's just over at that
point like there's nothing there's
nothing that we can do as an industry to
fix it we can only do what we can do
inside of our particular companies to
like claim a larger percentage of the
people that are actually graduating so
you know I think that there's a lot of
stuff that the tech community needs to
start doing and actually already is
doing to like address the problem with
the source the second thing that happens
a lot is it's amazing how many you know
women and minorities move out of
engineering like it's a huge brain drain
like you'll have all these people that
starts as software engineers and then
like you'll fast forward in ten months
ten years later their product managers
their TPMS they're you know they're
they're moving out of an area that they
think is unfriendly to them into an area
that they think is more friendly to them
so there's there's a role that you know
I think that all of our leaders have to
play and the team has to play on making
this choice for the people that we have
work really well right like make them
feel very welcome in our teams make them
feel very well supported you know be the
wrath of God on anyone that like
questions that or interferes with it in
any way like so that's the second part
and that's something that everybody here
can do you know like we're all probably
in a team with a diverse person of some
kind you know so think about like what
are you doing to make sure that they
like their job and they're sticking
around and they're not gonna like opt
out of it because it's too much of a
pain in the ass I want to make sure also
like when we say diverse because I don't
just mean gender diversity because I do
think sometimes you know like for me
myself like I feel like I come from a
like a socioeconomically a pretty
privileged background and you know just
because of a gender diversity part
there's probably a lot of other people
who
much harder for them to get into the
industry and stay in there yeah
absolutely
diversity is across all of those like so
many intersectionality as I put the term
out there and across a lot of things I
mean there's a lot of inclusion work
that needs to happen as well but until
companies start not just relying on
resumes at the top of the funnel I think
we have a long road ahead of us because
if you have somebody that's looking at
it and unless they're really well
trained and you've put a lot of work
into making your recruiting teams
cognizant of the fact that the resume is
limited and they can't just look for the
same five things over and over you're
gonna filter your top of the funnel
wrong so I I strongly believe in some
kind of process where you know anybody
can show what they can do that's what
I'm trying to build but there are plenty
of other things that can be done as well
but yeah it's also not so it's there are
no low-hanging fruit here like companies
have to change their process and and
from how they hire and how they retain
people and it's not just about sourcing
or women or sourcing more people of
color or anything it's like you have to
change how you think about hiring and
that there's just like data science
isn't a magic bullet for your data
problems right data science like there's
there's no single thing that's gonna
make this better and it's hard and it's
gonna take a long time but there are
more and more women and and people of
color in this field university students
look very different than people that
have been in this industry for 10 years
and on our platform we have close to
gender parity among juniors and it drops
off for seniors so the next five to ten
years I'm very very optimistic and I'm
starting to turn I think the
demographics are starting to yeah
they're starting to turn people become
role models because I think one other
thing that's so hard right now why
people leave is because they don't have
role models so they can look up to and
understand how the past can play up
you